bonsoir bonsoir qui est le Réseau
canadien de recherche partenariale sur
la philanthropie donc vous êtes vraiment
spécialisé dans la philanthropie si je
vous demandais d'abord qu'est-ce qu'on
sait sur la philosophie philanthropique
de Jeff buzzers
il a dit je vais donner de mon vivant
c'est un apôtre du transhumanisme qui
vise à repousser la mort et à ce qu'on
vive le plus longtemps possible alors
peut-être que ce vivant va durer bien
bien longtemps cette boutade mise à part
le style de philanthropie de Jeff Bezos
pour l'instant ça s'incarne ça s'inspire
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle le
philanthrop capitalisme c'est à dire
transposer des manières de faire qui
viennent du monde des affaires au monde
de la philanthropie j'ai réussi dans les
affaires j'ai été le meilleur je peux
transposer ce savoir-faire là pour
régler des problèmes sociaux
environnementaux donc à la fois il y a
cette espèce de rhétorique de je suis un
visionnaire je vais réussir là où les
autres n'ont pas réussi donc y compris
je ne veux pas faire comme les autres
par exemple signer le giving Paige se
distinguer et puis miser sur les
mécanismes de marché les solutions du
marché la technologie pour les problèmes
sociaux et environnementaux est-ce que
c'est très différent du Gavin plage dont
on parle ici 2010 le give in plage lancé
par Bill Gates et Warren Buffett c'est
la même démarche de dire on va donner de
notre vivant après c'est pas parce qu'on
donne qu'on le fait de la même manière
et il peut avoir des philosophies
extrêmement différents Jeff Bezos on
sent qu'il va avoir les mains sur le
volant qui veut diriger par exemple son
fond son fond pour la protection de la
terre c'est lui qui le dirige donc on
sent pour l'instant encore que c'est
c'est lui qui a vraiment qui qui dirige
il y a pas encore une fondation il y a
pas encore derrière j'allais dire une
structure avec des spécialistes des
experts il y a pas encore une épaisseur
importante on sent qu'il est vraiment en
première ligne lui et sa femme et sa
nouvelle femme
et donc il y a un mélange un peu de à la
fois de vie personnelle de côté
professionnel de très grand amateurismes
aussi faut se souvenir en 2017 il
twitait j'ai envie de donner quelqu'un à
titre des idées grosso modo
tout le monde avait la main exactement
et donc après ça s'est développé mais ça
fait peu de temps en fait qu'il donne il
entend était le mauvais élève de la
philanthropie des très grandes fortunes
américaines est-ce que il y a une
stratégie fiscale derrière ça il y a
toujours une stratégie fiscale parce que
à ce niveau-là c'est évident qu'il y a
des conseillers qui trouvent des
manières mais j'allais dire il y a aussi
une réflexion sur le sur le type de
créature philanthropique qu'on va créer
je dis ça parce que dans les dernières
années par exemple monsieur Mark
Zuckerberg quand il a créé sa propre
structure il a pas créé une fondation
comme on a l'habitude de le voir il a
créé une autre structure une niche un
peu dans le dans le code dans le droit
aux États-Unis qui fait que c'est pas
une fondation donc elle peut faire aussi
des profits une sorte d'hybridation
entre la Fondation l'entreprise privée
on fait de la philanthropie en faisant
des affaires on fait des affaires
ensemble la philanthropie donc il y a
aussi au niveau des cadres légaux toute
une réflexion sur faire des dons aussi
investir aller chercher des rendements
donc il y a un très grand flou encore il
faudra lire entre les lignes et les
toutes petites lignes pour comprendre
comment ça va se passer
au Canada par exemple au Québec est-ce
que est-ce qu'on a des comparables à ce
qu'on voit aux États-Unis que ce soit le
Gavin plage ou aujourd'hui l'exemple de
Jeff Bezos on a des comparables toute
proportion gardée en termes de
évidemment de montant mais on peut
penser par exemple il y a peu de temps
et disparu monsieur Chagnon qui était le
fondateur de André Chagnon de l'Empire
québécois qui a créé la Fondation Lucie
André Chagnon c'était la plus grande
fondation du Canada et la plus grande
formation au Québec aujourd'hui c'est la
deuxième formation du Canada mais c'est
une très grande fondation puis ce qui
est intéressant c'est de voir que les
fondations aussi elles évoluent dans les
premières années la fondation chanion il
y avait vraiment cette impulsion
entrepreneuriale d'une famille qui avait
réussi dans les affaires et qui donnait
cette impulsion de on va décider et un
peu de on va nous prendre les décisions
et ensuite y compris pour les organismes
financés ils vont devoir s'adapter et
cette fondation là a beaucoup évolué en
20 ans et aujourd'hui beaucoup plus une
posture de l'expertise elle est dans les
groupes qui sont en première ligne elle
est dans les populations qui vivent les
difficultés et donc nous on doit les
soutenir au mieux du côté de Monsieur
Bezos pour l'instant on sent que il est
pas là du tout et c'est lui qui dirige
c'est lui qui sait et qu'il faut le
suivre en gros à partir du 1er janvier
2023 au Canada le gouvernement fédéral
va faire passer de 3,5 à
5%, le décaissement obligatoire annuel
pour les fondations ça a peut-être l'air
un peu technique mais c'est important
comme décision c'est très important
parce que c'est des montants qui sont
extrêmement extrêmement conséquents
donc c'était une demande il faut savoir
que dans le passé ça déjà été 5% au
Canada et puis on était revenu à trois
et demi pour cent après 2008 la crise
financière des des organisations avait
perdu beaucoup d'argent avec la crise
financière donc ça fait une demande de
baisser ce quota de décaissement sauf
que dans les dernières années il faut
donner 3 millions 500 c'est là on va
passer à 5 millions exactement parce
qu'en fait les fondations privées sont
basées sur un qui est placé sur les
marchés financiers elles sont devenues
elles ont fait beaucoup d'argent pour le
dire comme ça et quelque part il y a eu
beaucoup de demandes pour dire mais là
il faut revenir à un niveau plus
important à la fois parce que les
caisses sont pleines et aussi parce que
les besoins auxquels on fait face sont
de plus en plus importants si on parle
des enjeux environnementaux c'est
aujourd'hui que ça se passe c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il faut sortir de
l'argent et énormément d'argent donc il
y a une réflexion aussi du côté des
fondations oui d'obligation sur le fait
de devoir dépenser 5% mais certaines
vont plus loin en disant sur certains
enjeux
ça sert à rien de vouloir être éternel
comme fondation c'est maintenant qu'il
faut agir il faut donner beaucoup plus
parce que les besoins parce que
l'opportunité de changer les choses
avant que ce soit trop tard c'est
maintenant
les réflexions aujourd'hui qui sont
importantes de mieux entropique monsieur
c'est très intéressant c'est même
passionnant le monde philanthropique
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir ça
m'a fait plaisir c'est beaucoup pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI